I am Nick Gillespie with Reason TV today
we're talking to recent senior editor
Radley Balko about the militarization of
American law enforcement
Bradley thanks for talking Thanks let's
talk about the Missouri the Columbia
Missouri arrayed which you wrote about
for reason went viral and provoked a
huge outcry what happened in Columbia
Missouri what happened is you had a the
police got a tip from one informant and
then I guess another one that this guy
had a large stash of marijuana in his
house they did what they call a trash
pole and they found a remnants of
America that's where they sort through
garbage yeah they sorted the family's
garbage that the garbage outside the
house and they found a small I think it
was Rendon's of marijuana in a plastic
bag that was the intelligence for the
raid these tips and then the bag and
they were told it was very high-grade
marijuana which see that phrase appears
over through the warrant so they eight
days later they conduct the SWAT raid
that's depicted in the video it's a very
typical squad raid they come in they
break down the door they announce
himself they do announce themselves
although I would argue you know if you
were asleep in the house or you in a
room in the back whether or not they
announced would these were the relevant
the person would here is the door coming
down and then Shannon took place at 8:30
8:30 and 9:00 and so the inside there
was the the suspect and then also his
wife and an eight-year-old boy the they
shot I guess they put off seven rounds
aimed at the pitbull the family had a
pit bull in a corgi one of the shots at
least one the shots missed but one of
them ricocheted and and struck the Corgi
as well they killed the the pit bull and
you see you know it's a it's extremely
violent sort of difficult to watch video
the dogs you know whining after they
shoot it before they finish it off you
know you see the boys for being shuffled
through the house you know passed the
bodies of the dogs passed the SWAT
officers and the guns and then the guy
well that they arrest you know he was up
against the wall he's in hand
and he finds out that they shot his dog
and you know just sort of goes ballistic
you know why did you kill my dog why'd
you kill my dog and he wanted to play
with you and I think it really resonated
with a lot of people because you know I
found when I write about this issue when
you talk about a person for example
getting shot people tend to it's clear
if they had shot the kid you know
accidents happen right it'd be a suspect
you know the person probably did
something wrong you know but when you
talk about the pets getting killed that
tends to keep people sort of agitated so
with witness read the intelligence I
mean they had informants we I mean do we
know who the informants were now they
never really reveal that except in very
very extreme situations but they they
didn't find you know they found a
misdemeanor amount of POD in fact
marijuana for personal use has been
decriminalized in Colombia they they
didn't even find enough pot to give them
a citation they charged him and had to
drop the charge later you have talked
both before you joined reason at Cato in
your excellent study overkill about the
power militarization of American Police
the use of SWAT SWAT tactics for
everyday operations what give us a quick
sketch what's been going on in terms of
the the kind of writing up of American
police force well I mean I think as the
politicians have sort of really stepped
up the drug war rhetoric starting I
guess probably in the early 1980s the
drug war has the war aspect of that has
become very literal we've seen a program
a federal program where the Pentagon is
giving away military equipment to local
police departments and literally
millions of pieces of military equipment
everything from you know guns and tanks
and armored personnel carriers and
helicopters to you know more mundane
things like office equipment has been
transferred from the Pentagon to these
local police departments across the
country who I mean realistically don't
even really know how to use it I mean
not as a NOC and their professionalism
but I mean it's it's above their pay
grade isn't it really well I mean
there's a good example is the the
Richland County South Carolina Sheriff
has a armored personnel carrier that has
a 360 degree rotating turret with a
belt-fed machine gun that shoots 50
caliber
munition and this is an urban area the
military the US military has
restrictions on when they use 50 Cal you
know it'll go through four or five city
blocks before it stops this is sort of
an example of the kind of insanity I
think that we're looking at the way the
sort of war imagery has been implemented
what
how many raids how many kind of
militarized raids or SWAT raids get done
in a given day in America it's about 100
150 a day or about 50,000 a year and
it's probably even higher than that
because all the trends that sort of got
us there you know none of those trends
have gone away so what what is the
typical target of a SWAT raid or of a
paramilitary right well and that's the I
mean I think the really powerful thing
about this Missouri video is that this
was a very typical raid this was not a
botched raid this was not you know no
one was killed they got the right
address they arrested the guy they were
looking for and they you know they found
some enough drugs to at least initially
charge him most of these raids really
went when newspapers have done surveys
after a raid has gone wrong they found
that most of these raids result in
misdemeanor charges they don't typically
turn up huge amounts of drugs or weapons
now you know a good percentage than they
do but it's not a majority and I think
that that that's really sort of the the
lesson to take away from this videos for
all the outrage they're really generated
across the internet I think it's up to
1.3 1.4 million views on YouTube now
this is a very typical rate I mean this
is the kind of thing that happens all
the time even you know right down to the
shooting of the dogs who's driving this
train wreck is that the cops is that
politicians is that the public is that
the drug dealers a lot of the outrage on
the internet when this video and file
was directed at the Columbia Police
Department and at the individual
officers involved in this raid and as I
mentioned I mean this raid was very
typical and it was very routine I think
a lot of that anger was wasn't this
placed I think the blame here really
belongs on the politicians who have
implemented these policies who continue
to talk about drugs and the drug war in
with war imagery and you know that that
has an effect both on how you know what
sort of policies we implement it has
effect on the mindset of the police
officers who we ask to enforce these
laws so I mean that you know the all the
anger and and there are even some death
threats directed at the
Columbia police officers I mean really
this is probably going on in your
community also I mean they're absurdly
small towns with SWAT teams now and I
think the anger really needs to be
directed at the politicians who continue
to push these sort of these policies
that that result in what you see in that
video who shot the video and how did it
come to public view the video was
actually shot by a member of the police
department and the attorney for the
family has told me actually that all the
the raids for this department or
videotapes they're not all released
public and what happened in this case
the family actuary initially requested a
copy of the video and they were sent a
copy that had the audio removed and had
key portions but some of the more sort
of emotional parts of the video removed
the newspaper a local newspaper at the
Columbia newspaper then had heard from
neighbors and heard from the family that
this has gone on that there was a video
they requested a copy weren't Ischl II
denied and then they followed up with a
sort of formal open records request and
that's when the video was released to
them they posted it on their website and
then I posted it on the reason side a
couple days later and that's when it
went viral what are what are the the key
things that have to happen for this
trend to reverse or to disappear well I
mean the most obvious solution would be
to end the drug war and then the idea
that government has you know any
business protecting us from ourselves
the second would be to to reign in SWAT
teams to so they're only performing in
the ways that they were originally
designed to perform which is to respond
to an already violent situation to you
know respond to bank robberies and
school shootings and terrorist incidents
that kind of thing the third I think is
is to videotape all these these raids
and I think this serves a number of
important functions one is you know it
would clear up any misunderstandings or
disagreements about what happened during
the raid which would you know both
implicate officers when they do
something wrong but also indemnify them
against false claims and false
accusations the second thing I think
videotaping on the raids would do is it
would force the police officers to be
sort of adopt best standards and
practices you know they're gonna be on
their best behavior if they know
everything they do during the raid is
going to be
tape and then finally you know and this
is more of an argument toward the
general public to support this idea of
videotaping them but you know the
reaction this raid was so powerful
because people actually saw what what
happens during a very typical SWAT raid
for a drug offense and I think that the
videotaping all of them and making the
videotapes making the tapes available to
the public would bring a sort of level
of transparency to the drug war it
really forced the public to confront
what they're supporting and and really
sort of see how the drug war is carried
out on a day to day to day basis and I
think you would probably see support for
reform at least sort of moving to a less
militaristic way of enforcing the drug
laws right well Radley I want to thank
you I'm Nick Gillespie for Reason TV
we've been talking to reasons Radley
Balko about the paramilitaries a ssin of
american police